Hey! Tutaj ponownie Thoughty2
Mineło już prawie 50 lat od momentu kiedy Illuminati zapłacili NASA dwa miliony dolarów zęby ci zapłacili milion dolarów Stanleyowi Kubrickowi
za spreparowanie lądowania na księżycu na parkingu w Roswell.
Wszystko to tylko po to aby zmusić Rosjan do poddania się i nie wybudowania tak cennej fabryki serów na księżycu.
Żarty na bok,
Kogo tak na prawdę obchodzi Księżyc ?
Co on takiego dla nas zrobił?
Przecież to tylko wielki kawał skały, do którego okazjonalnie psy szczekają a czasami włazi w drogę słońcu.
Racja ?
Wiec, jaki wpływ na naszą planetę ma właściwie Księżyc ?
Czy życie bez niego byłoby inne ?
Czas najwyższy się dowiedzieć.
Jak Ważny Jest Księżyc?
Pierwsze co musimy wiedzieć to jak to się stało że mamy Księżyc.
Nikt nie był świadkiem jego powstania także nie ma na to definitywnej odpowiedzi.
Jest możliwość, że tak Ziemia jak i Księżyc powstały równocześnie z tego samego kosmicznego materiału
jakieś 4.5 miliarda lat temu. Ta teoria niestety nie wyjaśnia dlaczego na Księżycu jest tak mało metali w porównaniu z ziemią.
Jeżeli dwa obiekty zostały utworzone z tych samych materiałów to można by oczekiwać że będą miały bardzo podobny skład.
Kolejna teoria mówi o pewnej części , płynnej wówczas skorupy ziemskiej wystrzelonej na orbitę za pomocą siły odśrodkowej obracającej się Ziemi.
Niestety, żeby tak uformować księżyc potrzebujemy monstrualnej siły odśrodkowej,
która z pewnością, popsułaby dinozaurom niejeden dzień:)
Może to było bezpańskie ciało niebieskie, wędrujące w przestrzeni kosmicznej, które zostało przechwycone przez Ziemię ?
Do tego jednak, potrzebnaby nam była dużo większa atmosfera, która zwolniłaby dryfujący obiekt i
zatrzymała go. Jednak najbardziej prawdopodobne jest, że obiekt wielkości Marsa, który został nazwany "Strach"
zderzył się z nasza planeta. Cześć materiału z tego potwornego zderzenia wróciło na ziemie
a reszta materiału, która pozostała na orbicie w przeciągu około roku czasu
uformowała się w Ksieżyc. To zdarzyło się jakieś 50 milionów lat po tym jak skończył się formować nasz układ słoneczny.
Częściowo utwardzona, świeżo uformowana planeta, w wyniku kolizji została z powrotem przywrócona do stanu płynnego
przez co nie pozostał żaden ślad po uderzeniu.
To również wyjaśnia różnicę w ilości metali miedzy Ziemia a Księżycem.
Ciężki, metalowy rdzeń "Strachu" dzięki swojej masie, mógł zostać przyciągnięty do rdzenia naszej planety,
gdzie lżejszy materiał pozostał na orbicie by po pewnym czasie uformować Księżyc.
Tak więc "Strach" najprawdopodobniej przyczynił się do zmiany przyspieszenia obrotu naszej planety. Jednak w momencie kiedy Księżyc by  nie utrzymał się blisko Ziemi
wtedy bylibyśmy skazani na dni długości od 6 do 8 godzin . To znaczy, że średni mecz kriketa
trwałby około miesiąca. Księżyc spowalnia obrót ziemi dzięki zjawisku tarcia pływowego.
Za każdym razem kiedy ciągnie ocean pare metrów od plaży, co nie tylko rujnuje nasze zamki z piasku
ale powoduje też tarcie pomiędzy masą wody a dnem oceanu co przenosi się na mały uszczerbek w trwaniu roku.
Ta energia oddziałowuje też na Księżyc,
powoduje wybrzuszenie w oceanie, które przekłada sie na "ciagniecie" Księżyca
Ten extra kopniak przyśpiesza Księżyc ale zwalnia Ziemię.
W taki sposób tracimy kilka milisekund w ciągu roku.
Co oznacza, że za jakieś 4 miliony lat rok przestępny nie będzie już potrzebny.
Sam Księżyc oddala się od Ziemi o jakieś 3 lub więcej centymetrów rocznie.
Jednak, siły pływowe, poza powodowaniem tarcia pełnią także dużo ważniejsza rolę.
Życie wyewoluowało w oceanach.
Weźcie pod uwagę, że jest dużo łatwiej przetrwać w ciepłych prądach wodnych niż na małym kawałku skały wulkanicznej.
Jednak, tak jak możecie zauważyć  rozgladając się dookoła, udało nam sie uciec z oceanów i poradzić sobie
z nie za lekkim życiem na suchych kawałkach naszej planety.
Coś jak X-men.
W tym wszystkim pływy grają dwie ważne role:
Po pierwsze. Miliardy lat temu, kiedy życie się formowało , Księżyc był dużo bliżej nas.
Mniej więcej połowę odległości w jakiej znajduje się teraz.
Dzięki temu oddziaływanie Księżyca było czterokrotnie większe,
co powodowało dużo większe przypływy i odpływy.
Molekularny Biolog Richard Iave mówi, że to by spowodowało tworzenie się dużych
obszarów odpływowych cechujących się dużym zasoleniem.
To powodowało wyparowywanie wody
i tworzenie środowiska, które
było odpowiednie do powstania aminokwasów,
które będą łączyć się w łańcuchy, dając początek formowaniu się skomplikowanych form życia.
Po drugie. kiedy życie w oceanach zaczęło się mnożyć i ewoluować
każdy wodny organizm żyjący na linii brzegowej często stawał o obliczu bycia pozostawionym na brzegu
z dala od wody, wtedy kiedy Księżyc powodował odpływ.
Biedny organizm miał do wyboru toń albo płyń lub bardziej trafnie, uduś się albo oddychaj.
Oczywiście życie zaczęło się adoptować do nowych warunków
i po pewnym czasie pojawiły się formy życia radzące sobie z życiem poza oceanem.
Oczywiście, mielibyśmy przypływy także bez księżyca
a to dzięki grawitacji Słońca
ale byłyby to przypływy o połowę mniejsze od tych, które obecnie mamy.
Cały efekt to połączone siły Słońca i Księżyca, które powodują efekt sprężynowy.
Jednak bez Księżyca powodującego mocne pływy, proces ewolucyjny nie byłby  aż tak szybki...
Jednak bez Księżyca powodującego mocne pływy, proces ewolucyjny nie byłby aż tak szybki....
...a nas, najprawdopodobniej by nie było.
Połączone działanie Słońca i Księżyca
jest bardzo ważne dla noktowizji.
Światło odbite od Księżyca jest tylko jedną czterysta-tysięczna blasku naszej gwiazdy
pomimo tego ilość odbitego od Księżyca światła jest tysiące razy wyższa od innych   jasnych obiektów na nocnym niebie
pomimo tego ilość odbitego od Księżyca światła jest tysiące razy wyższa od innych   jasnych obiektów na nocnym niebie.
Jeżeli w bezksiężycową noc wyjedziecie za miasto zdacie sobie sprawę jak ograniczona jest widoczność bez odbitego przez Księżyc światła.
Najprawdopodobniej zjadł by was niedźwiedź
ponieważ na wsi jest od zatrzęsienia niedźwiedzi i węży:)
Gdyby nocne niebo było dużo ciemniejsze nocne zwierzęta rozwinęłyby się w innym kierunku,
ograniczony dostęp światła popchałby ewolucję w stronę echolokacji ale to nie znaczy, że przestałyby istnieć organizmy widzące w nocy.
Niektóre gatunki takie jak Zmrocznik Gładysz (Deilephila elpenor)
są tak dobrze przystosowane do życia w nocy, że rozróżniają nawet kolory
są tak dobrze przystosowane do życia w nocy, że rozróżniają nawet kolory.
Dla odmiany, ludzkie oko już w świetle pół -księżyca dostaje tak mało światła, że przestajemy widzieć kolory
Dla odmiany, ludzkie oko już w świetle pół -księżyca dostaje tak mało światła, że przestajemy widzieć kolory i widzimy tylko odcienie szarości.
Po zachodzie słońca, bez światła księżycowego bylibyśmy dużo bardziej narażeni na nocne niebezpieczeństwa.
Księżyc jest także odpowiedzialny za stabilizacje osi odchylania ziemi względem słońca.
Oś odchylenia ziemi jest bardzo podobna do kąta odchylania Marsa, to jest około 24 stopnie.
Z jedną istotną różnica, oś odchylenia Marsa nie jest stabilna
co powoduje czasowe odchylenia w zakresie 15 do 35 stopni.
Sytuacja na Ziemi wyglądała by bardzo podobnie
gdyby nie stabilizujące działanie naszego satelity.
Co więcej, tego typu zachowanie byłoby koszmarem dla naszego ekosystemu.
Wyobraźcie sobie bardzo nieregularne pory roku
takie jak...trzyletnia zima.
To sumie tak jak normalne warunki w północnej Anglii....no odejmując obecność White Walkersów oczywiście.
Dziękuję za oglądniecie, zapraszam do subskrypcji na więcej od Thoughty2.
W tym jeziorze odkryto setki ludzkich szkieletów....
.... z tego wynika, że może jesteś bardzo inteligentny, nawet na poziomie geniusza.